السلام عليكم ورحمه الله واهلا بكم في
موعدنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليومي بموازاه قصف مكثف وغير مسبوق تشنه
قواته على منطقه خان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه
اوقع فيها اكثر من 160 مدنيا بين شهيد
وجريح قطع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو امل عائلات المحتجزين في
غزه بابلاغ عدم وجود ما سماه عرضا مناسبا
وذا سله يصلح من وجهه نظره اساسا للتوصل
الى اتفاق لاعاده ذويها خبر لا يبدو انه
فاجا عائلات الاسرى التي اقتحم افراد منها
قبيل ذلك اجتماع لجنه المال في الكنيست
بالقدس الغربيه مطالبين بالافراج عن
ابنائهم تصعيد ياتي ضمن سلسله اجراءات لجا
اليها اهالي المحتجز
كان اخرها دخولهم في اعتصام مفتوح امام
مقر اقامه نتنياهو في ظل تزايد القلق على
سلامه الاسرى مع مرور الوقت بعد تقارير عن
تعرضهم لخطر هجمات جيشهم وتاكيد والده
احدهم مقتل ثلاثه منهم بغاز سام اطلقه جيش
الاحتلال داخل احد الانفاق في
غزه وازاء تصاعد الحديث عن قضيه المحتجزين
وازدياد القنا بتعارض امكانيه استعادتهم
مع استمرار الحرب على غزه كما يقول
نتنياهو اعلن حزب العمل استعداده لدعم
قرار بوقف اطلاق النار في غزه مقابل
استعاده المحتجزين اذا لزم الامر ملتحقا
بذلك بموقف زعيم المعارضه ياير لابيد الذي
طالب بدوره باجراء انتخابات مبكره دعا
نتنياهو للجلوس والاتفاق بشان موعدها حتى
لا تضر بالمجهود الحربي حسب تعبيره و في
مقابل هذا التوجه يمضي حلفاء نتنياهو من
اليمين المتطرف في الحديث عن خطتهم لما
بعد السيطره على غزه مع تاكيد رفضهم اي
اتجاه لوقف اطلاق النار مهما كانت
الاعتبارات بل ورهن استمرارهم في الحكومه
بمواصله الحرب على غزه رغم اقرارهم
بالشعور بالاحباط للفشل في هزيمه حماس حتى
الان اما على مستوى الشارع الاسرائيلي فقد
كشف استطلاع للراي اجرته القناه الثالث عش
ان اكثر من نصف من شملهم يرون ان مصالح
نتنياهو الشخصيه هي اهم ما يوجه قراراته
تجاه الحرب كما كشف الاستطلاع ايضا وفق سي
ان ان ان حزب الليكود والائتلاف اليمني
اليميني الحاكمين سيخسر بالتاكيد اي
انتخابات يمكن ان تجرى
[موسيقى]
الان نرحب بضيفي في هذه الحلقه من الناصر
الكاتب المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
ايهاب جبارين وننتظر ان ينضم الينا من
الخليل الدكتور بلال الشبكي رئيس قسم
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الخليل السيد
ايهاب جبارين واضح ان منطق نتنياهو يختلف
تماما عن منطق اهالي المحتجزين كيف يمكن
ان تسير هذه المواجهه ان صح وصفها
كذلك نعم تحياتي لك استاذ محمد ولضيوفك
الكرام بطبيعه الحال نتنياهو انا باعتقادي
يعيش صراع لقبين اللقب الاول هو سيد ماربي
تحون سيد الامن هذا اللقب هو الصقه لنفسه
على مدار سنوات الاولى منذ ان دخل الى هذه
الحكومه بانه هو الوحيد الذي يستطيع ان
يجلب ايه الامن الى اسرائيل هذه كانت
حملته الانتخابيه في عام 2009 ومنذ ذلك
اليوم هو صار في استراتيجيه جدا بسيطه ب
لا يدخل اسرائيل في ايه غمار ايه معركه او
حرب طويله الامد بل كانت كل الحروبات او
كل العدوان الذي يقوم به هو مجرد حروب
خاطفه 2014
2015 2018 كلياتها حروب خاطفه بدون اي
تصعيد ربما حتى هو كتب ذلك بخط يده في
وثيقه في عام 2018 بانه لكي يستطيع ان
يقتل القضيه الفلسطينيه هو بحاجه لتوتر
متواتر بدون ايه موجه تصعيد هذا اللقب
الاول اللقب الثاني هو اللقب الذي الصقه
به الشارع الاسرائيلي شكران بن شكران كذاب
ابن كذاب وبطبيعه الحال هذه هي ازمه الثقه
التي يعتاش الان بنيامين نتنياهو الشارع
الاسرائيلي لا يثق به نهائيا الشارع
الاسرائيلي يعلم جيدا ان كل ما يحاول ان
يقوم به بنيامين نتنياهو يقود هذه المعركه
التي لا تجلب الامن في المقام الاول التي
حتى يعني خسر بها لقب سيد الامن او رجل
الامن الذي كان يمتاز به على مدى كل هذه
السنوات خسر هذا اللقب فقط لكي يسير في
طريق الهروب الى الامام هذا ما كل ما يقوم
به بنيامين نتنياهو في هذه المرحله من
استراتيجيات هذا ما يدركه الشارع
الاسرائيلي هذا ما يدركه شركائه في داخل
الكابينت حتى هنالك ازمه ثقه حقيقيه في
داخل الكابينت عندما تصل الامور الى حد
الاحتدام بالايدي او عراك شبه عراك ما
بينه وبين وزيره هذا يعني يفضي لنا عن مدى
الارباك والصراع الذي يعيشه هذه الكابينت
وانا باعتقادي انها ليست مجرد شائعات او
مجرد تسريبات لكي يستطيع ان يعني يحتوي
بها نوع من مسار الامور او ما الى ذلك هي
امور حقيقيه بل اكثر من ذلك بنيامين
نتنياهو على مدى كل هذه السنوات بربما
اشاره تجدر الاشاره اليها بانه كان يحاول
ان يمتطي وزراء دفاعه كان يخاف من وزراء
دفاعه يحاول ان ينطيهم ويحاول ان يقبر في
داخل تلك الوزاره هذه كانت استراتيجيه
واضحه مردخاي مفاز براك
يعلون يعني يمكن الوحيد الذي لم يخافه
ويخشاه بنيامين نتنياهو وليبرمان لانه لم
ياتي مع ايه خلفيه عسكريه نهائيا فبالتالي
هو كان وما زال حتى هذه اللحظه يخاف رجال
الامن يخاف رجال الامن والعسكر في داخل
الكابينت ويحاول ان يراوغ ما بين كل هذه
المسميات لكي يستمر في هروبه الى الامام
وفق هذه الاستراتيجيه نعم يعني طالما
طالما انه شكران بن شكران مثل ما ذكرت
بالتعبير العبري كما يوصف يعني كذاب بن
كذاب ايه ربما نسال الدكتور بلال الشوبكي
نتنياهو قال وفق يدعوه احرنوت
عندما التقى اهالي المحتجزين قال لهم لا
يوجد اي مقترح حقيقي من
حماس هناك فقط مبادره من جانبنا ولن اخوض
في تفاصيلها يتعلق تتعلق باطلاق سراح
المحتجزين لكنه في بيانه المتلفز يقول
شروط حماس لاطلاق سراح المحتجزين هي شروط
استسلام اذا هناك هناك عرض يعني على عكس
ما يقوله وا ايضا هذا يتناقض مع ما قالته
الفاينانشال تايمز من ان هناك محادثات
لصفقه رهائن تطبخ بين قطر ومصر والولايات
المتحده ولكن واضح ان المواقف بشانها
مازالت
متباعده كيف ترى هذا التناقض في تصريحات
نتنياهو هذا جزء من يعني اسلوب بمين
نتنياهو الذي تفضل بالاشاره اليه الاستاذ
ايهاب يعني هو يذب على كافه الاطراف بهدف
البقاء يعني في المساحه الامنه البقاء في
المساحه الرماديه التي لا يقرر فيها يعني
اسلوب بنيمين نتنياهو منذ السابع من
اكتوبر حتى هذه اللحظه انه لا يتخذ قرارات
يعني في كل مره يلقى فيها يعني بن تنياه
الى مواقع او الى زوايا يجب ان يتخذ فيها
قرار سواء فيما يتعلق بخفقه التبادل او
فيما يتعلق باليوم الثاري لقطع غزه او
فيما يتعلق حتى بطبيعه العمليات العسكريه
هو يدرك تمام الا ان اي قرار يمكن اتخاذه
نتد لنتنياهو لن يلقى رضى كافه الاطراف
وبالتالي هو معني دائما بالبقاء في هذه
المساحه التي لا يقرر فيها ان اجتمع بمجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي لا يقرر
وبحكومة قول ان هذه الصفقه شروطها هي يعني
معناها استسلام لهذه الحركه معنى ان هذا
الرجل فقط يقدم ما يريد ان يستمع اليه
الناس لكن برايي اسلوب بنيمين نتنياهو
اصبح مكشوفا ومفضوح حتى للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي بمعنى انه يدرك الان انه لديه
شارعين وليس شارع في اسرائيل وبالتالي هو
يعلم جيدا مهما اتخذ من قرارات فيها
محاوله استرضاء هذا الشارع المنتصب ضد
سياسات بنيمين نتنياهو فان هذا الشارع لم
رب بمعنى وصل الى مرحله لا غفران في
الشارع الاسرائيلي او في جزء من الشارع
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هو يستثمر في الشارع
الاخر وهي القاعده اليمينيه الطلبه ولذلك
نراه لا يبدي اي استعداد لابداء نوع من
المرونه حتى حتى هذه اللحظه فيما يتعلق
بالقضايا المختلف عليها الان اسرائيليا
يعني الجميع في اسرائيل الان هم ليسوا ضد
الحرب الجميع في اسرائيل مع فتره الحرب
لكن مع التوفيف الان كيف يمكن ان يديروا
هذه المساله لذلك هو مي الان قدر الامكان
بمحاوله الاتقاء على هذه القاعده الصلبه
لانه ليس معميا بالضروره بان يكون هناك ر
من بي جانس ومن ايدن كور ليس بالضروره
معنيا برض من قبل الاداره الامريكيه هو
معني فقط لمحافظه على هذه القاعده
اليمينيه التي تبتزه يوميا سواء فيما
يتعلق بملفات مرتبطه بقطاع غزه او ملفات
مرتبطه بالدف الغربيه سيبقى بنيامين
نتنياهو يستمر في هذه المعادله بما انه
بنيامين نتنياهو يدرك حتى هذه اللحظه لانه
هذه المعادله نجحت يعني صحيح اننا نشير
دائما الىد ينطلق من موقع ضع ويكذب ويضلل
الجماهير لكن في نهايه المطاف نحن نتحدث
عن رجل استطاع حتى هذه اللحظه بهذا
الاسلوب البقاء في موقع الحكم ويبدو لي ان
جزء من المعارضه الاسرائيليه وهي معارضه
يعني فريده من نوعها هي جزء من المعارضه
خارج الحكومه ومعارضه موجوده في مجس الحرب
يعني معارضه من
الناحيه العمليه نظريا هي جزء من الح ككه
جزء منها متواقع بمعنى انه بامكانهم تغيير
المشهد السياسي الاسرائيلي بشكل او باخر
من خلال اتخاذ خطوات اكثر جراه فيما يتعلق
ببقائهم داخل مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي لكن
الارقام التي تظهر من خلال استطلاعات
الرعي تشير الى ان البقاء حتى هذه اللحظه
يقدمهم من حيث زياده رصيدهم الجماهيري
فيما بنيمين نتنياهو يخسر وبالتالي هم
ربما الان يفكروا بهذه العقليه الدفع
نتنياهو قدر الامكان بالاستمرار في كل هذه
الترهات التي يمكن ان تزيد من خسائر على
المستوى الجماهيري الى حين ان يسقط يعني
من الناحيه السياسيه ولذك ولكن اللاف
اللافت ان هناك استمرار في في التعارض بين
بين ما يقوله نتنياهو وما تقوله العائلات
سيد ايهاب جبارين يعني العائلات اصدرت
بيانا تحت عنوان نفذ الوقت وعلى فكره يشبه
ما ما ما تقوله ك اب القسام في فيديوهاتها
الوقت ينفد عنوان بيان
العائلات نفذ الوقت وتقول بان سياسه
الحكومه فيما يتعلق بموضوع المحتجزين هو
بمثابه اصدار حكم الاعدام بالضبط هذا هو
التعبير بالطريقه التي تدير بها الحكومه
ومع ذلك نتنياهو عندما التقى بهم ماذا
تنقل عنه القناه الثانيه عش انه قال لهم
بان لديه التزاما عميقا واخلاقيا باعاده
المختطفين عندما نرى تكثيف الغارات وتصعيد
الغارات على قطاع غزه دون اعتبار لحياه
المحتجزين طبعا دون اعتبار حياه
الفلسطينيين هذا تحصيل حاصل ولكن دون
اعتبار حتى لحياه المحتجزين الا يدل ذلك
انه لا يقيم وزنا لهؤلاء المحتجزين
وحياتهم على
الاطلاق هذا بن يعيدنا ال المربع الاول
بانه يكذب بل خطابه الاخير يمكن القول انه
ما يمتاز به في كل حياته وليس فقط في
الايام الاخيره بانه كل خطاباته تحديدا مع
الشارع الاسرائيلي هي دماغيه بالمقام
الاول ياتي بخطابات على مدى وقدراته
الدبلوماسيه المتمكنه ياتي اليهم بخطابات
شعبويا ويحاول ان يعني يملي عليهم ما يجب
ان يكون في المقام الاول او يسمعهم ما
يريدونه حتى في المقام الاول ولكنه يقوم
بما يجب ان يقوم به في المقام الثاني هذا
في في الجهه الجهه الاولى الجهه الثانيه
التي يجب ان ندركها بانه يقوم في ذات
الوقت الذي نتحدث به عن هذه الاشكاليه
يدير حروبات بالوكاله يدير جبهات بالوكاله
هنالك منتدى يسمى ها تيكفا الامل لذوي
الاسرى جزء صغير من ذوي الاسر الذين هم
مناوئون لبنيامين نتنياهو الذين هم
متواطئون مع بنيامين نتنياهو بسياساته
وب بتعبيره يعني اليوم جلسوا في احد لجان
الكنيست وقالوا بصريح العباره بانهم اي
صفقه قد تصل الى وقف اطلاق النار في نهايه
المطاف هذه قد تعرض امن اسرائيل الى الخطر
وبالتالي نحن بغنى عن مثل هذه الصفقات
مثلا على سبيل المثال يعني يستعمل كل هذه
الخطابات الديماغوجي والاساليب الديماغوجي
لكي يحارب ال ذوي الاسرى ببعضهم هو يعني
جلس معهم اي نعم ولكن هو يحاول ان يقول
لهم في نهايه الطريق ان هنالك ذوي اسرى
اخرون لديهم توجهات اخرى وانا يجب ان
البيها هذا في المقام الاول كان هنالك
كذلك نم اشاره مهمه جدا الى صفقه جلعاد
شليت صفقه يعني هم يشرون بان صفقه جلعاد
شليت هي التي سببت في نهايه المطاف الى
السابع من اكتوبر بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر
وبالتالي كذلك هو يديرها في ذات السيروره
وفي ذات الملف وفي ذات الدائره دائره
مفرغه في نهايه المطاف اي نعم لكن هذه هذا
من جهه اولى من جهه ثانيه وهي ربما كذلك
نقطه مهمه جدا تجدر الاشاره اليها انه في
ذات الوقت الان يخرج جنود الاحتياط يحاول
ان يقوم كذلك بعمليه استباقيه بعض من جنود
الاحتياط الذين خرجوا يقولون او يعني
رفعوا بعض اللافتات الذين يقولون بها نحن
خرجنا لكن بدون تحرير
الاسرى مع يعني لدينا شعور بخيبه الامل
لان خرجنا بدون تحرير الاسرى هذه اللافات
التي كانوا يفون اليوم عند بعد اذنك سيد
جبارين يعني العائلات وهي تكثف من اشكالها
الاحتجاجيه دكتور بلال شوبكي يعني عندما
تعتصم امام
مبنى امام بيت نتنياهو وعندما تقتحم لجنه
في في الكنيست هل تعتقد بان هذه الاشكال
ستزداد حده في
المستقبل يعني من يتابع طريقه تحرك
الجمهور الاسرائيلي منذ يعني بدايه الحرب
حتى هذه اللحظه اتخذ مستوى يعني مستويات
متعدده في البدايه الجمهور الاسرائيلي كان
مجيش بشكل كبير جدا لصالح هذه الحرب الى
درجه حتى ان ذوي المحتجز في بدايه الحرب
اندفعوا باتجاه كبير لتبني بعض مقولات
مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي وربما صدقوا مقولات
مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي من ان العمليه
العسكريه قد تؤدي الى استعاده المحتر ازين
لكن في مرحله لاحقه في مراحل لاحقه بمعنى
ان العامل الحاسم في تغيير مستوى تحرك ذوي
المحتجزين او المتعاطفين معهم ما يجري في
الميدان داخل قطاع غزه في كل يوم يتبين ان
هناك فشل في العمليات العسكريه ليس انا لا
اتحدث هنا بالضروره عن استهداف قدرات حركه
حماس وما الى ذلك لانه ذلك اشبع حديثا ال
الفشل كان في كيفيه توظيف المعلومات
الامنيه والقدرات العسكريه من اجل استعاده
المحتجزين يعني ح حتى حين توفرت بعض
المعلومات الامنيه ان كنتم تذكرون قبل
اسابيع حول احد المحتجزين فشلوا في
استخراجه من مكان احتجازه الى ان قتل في
ذلك الموقع وبالتالي اهالي المحتجزين في
هذه المرحله انتقلوا الى مستوى اخر ومستوى
التشكيك في العملي العسكريه بدا بدايه
كانوا مؤمنين بها انتقلوا الى التشكيك
بالعمليات العسكريه المستوى الثالث كان
بالتشكيك
بحتى القائمين على الامر في اسرائيل
وبالتالي ما نشهده الان الانتقال الى اخر
المستويات وهو شخصنه القضيه بمعنى انه في
اخر ايام بيني جانس وايزن كوت بداوا يعطوا
مؤشرات للجمهور الاسرائيلي انهم ليسوا
عقبه في طريق صفقه تبادل يمكن ان تؤدي الى
الافراج عن المحتجزين نعم ن لذلك الجمهور
الاسرائيلي تلقف هذه هذه الرسائل بشكل
واضح ان الازمه هي ازمه بنمي نتنياهو وهذا
هو الذي يفسر التوجه الان الى هذا الموضوع
و اعتقد ان المرحله القادمه ستشهد ليس فقط
مسيرات واعتصامات وانما اعاقه الى مسار
الحياه اليوميه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي بما
يشكل ضغطا اضافيا نعم فضيحه اخرى سيد
ايهاب جبارين تضاف الى فضيحه قتل ثلاثه من
المحتجزين مع انهم رفعوا والرايات البيضاء
عندما يفضح بان ربما ثلاثه من المحتجزين
ماتوا بغازات سامه سربت في
ال الانفاق
و هذا كلام قالته هارتس نقلا
عن ام لاحد هؤلاء بعد تشريح الجثه هذا
النوع من المقالات للمحتجزين هل ستزيد
الامر سوءا بالنسبه للحكومه رغم ان الكل
يقف ضد وقف الحرب كجزء من صفقه لاطلاق
سراح جميع
المحتجزين سؤال جميل يعني هي جزئيه كذلك
انه في نهايه المطاف المنطق يقوله ما
يقوله ايزنكوت ان الذي فقد ابنه في داخل
او قتل ابنه في داخل هذه الحرب في داخل
هذا العدوان هو يقول بكلمات جدا بسيطه بان
هذه الحرب لن
تحرر الاسرى باي شكل من الاشكال هذا ما
يقوله وبالتالي ضمن هذه المعادله يعني بات
واضحا للشارع الاسرائيلي احصائيا كذلك بان
كل المحاولات التي حاول بها جيش الاحتلال
بان يقوم بعمليات تحيير للاسرى باءت
بالفشل هي محاوله واحده بالمناسبه الجنديه
الاولى في اليوم التوغل البري الاول
وعليها الكثير من علامات الاستفهام عليها
الكثير من علامات الاستفهام بهذا المفهوم
وبالتالي هذه الجزئيه يعني باتت واضحه
بالنسبه للشا الان تبقى هنالك قضيه اخرى
ان في نهايه المطاف كل المالات التصعيد
كذلك يجب ان ناخذها من جانب اخر نتنياهو
في نهايه المطاف في اخر هذا الطريق او ما
ما بدا الان يقوم به الجيش هو بتسريح جنود
الاحتياط الخطوه التي كنا قد ذكرناها
بالنسبه لجنود الاحتياط هي ليست يعني
غريبه عن نتنياهو تحدثنا عن الحروبات
بالوكاله واضح جدا ان جز جزء لا باس به من
جنود الاحتياط الذين سوف يعودون الان الى
الشارع الاسرائيلي هم باعمار بين ال 30
الى ال 50 اغلبهم كانوا م ان قاضه
الاحتجاجات ضد بنيامين نتنياهو ما قبل
السابع من اكتوبر وهذا ما يخافه بنيامين
نتنياهو يجب ان نتذكر ان جنود الاحتياط
لعبوا دورا مركزيا في تلك الاحتجاجات
وموجه الاحتجاجات اضف الان احتجاجهم الى
جانب احتجاج ذوي الاسرى وبالذات في ظل عدم
فعاليه كل ما يقوم به نتنياهو من عمليه
عسكريه في داخل القطاع لتحرير الاسرى فل
هنالك من وصل به لان يقول بان واضح جدا ان
اهداف بنيامين نتنياهو هي قتل ايه ايه ايه
الاسرى واعاده حماس ليس العكس بالنسبه
بالمفاهيم الاسرائيليه فبالتالي واضح جدا
ان نتنياهو يعلم جيدا ان امامه موجه
احتجاجيه تصعيديه هذا ما يخافه بنيامين
نتنياهو ولهذا السبب يحاول ان يقوم بخطوات
استباقيه عبر تجنيد بضعا من جنود الاحتياط
لمعسكره عندما يقول نتنياهو
كما يشير هذا العاجل الذي على الشاشه بان
نتنياهو يقول العالم سيطالب ن بضمانات اذا
اوقفنا الحرب وعندها لن نتمكن من اعاده
شنها المشكله مثل ما اشار قبل قليل اسامه
حمدان السيد بلال الشوبكي قال نتنياهو لم
يستطع ان يطلق سراح محتجز واحد بالقوه
العسكريه ومع ذلك هو يؤكد ويصر هو والجميع
باننا سننتصر وسنطلق سراح كل المحتجزين
بالقوه لماذا هذا الاصرار على الفشل رغم
انه واضح
يعني يبدو لي ان بنيامين نتنياهو يعني
يختار ما بين مسالتين اما الموت الحاسم
السريع بوقف الحرب وبالتالي الذهاب الى
تغييرات
سياسيه يعني داخل اسرائيل وهذا يعني امر
محسوم سواء بالنسبه لبنيامين نتنياهو او
لخصوم بنيامين نتنياهو ان وقف الحرب حاليا
معنى في ضوء كل التقديرات سواء
الاسرائيليه او غير الاسرائيليه بان ه هذه
الحرب اذا ما توقفت الان فمعناه انها
هزيمه لاسرائيل لانهم لم يحققوا ولا هدف
واحد من الاهداف التي اعلنوها في بدايه
الحرب والخيار الثاني هو اختيار الموت
البطيء من خلال هذه العمليه العسكريه
واستمرارها بالتدريج على امل ان تحدث
معجزه يعني و وهنا بعض الكتاب
الاسرائيليين حدثوا تحدثوا عن ذلك بوضوح
ان بن يمين نتنياهو يقامر فقط هو يقامر كل
مره ويخسر لكن على امل ان تحدث معجزه في
قادم الايام ولذلك كل ما يقوم به بن يمين
نتنياهو الان هي بالعوده الى الفكره
السابقه البقاء في هذه المساحه التي لا
يقرر فيها مع احتماليه ان يحدث شيء في
المستقبل ولذلك هو حتى بات يكرر عبارات
فضفاضه قابله للتاويل يعني سابقا كان
يتحدث بشكل واضح استعاده المحتجزين
والقضاء على حركه حماس بدا يستخدم مصطلحات
قيميه غير قابله للقياس مثل قول الانتصار
الكبير او الانتصار الكامل كلمه انتصار
كبير او انتصار كامل يمكن لاي شخص يروجها
ان يقدم في نهايه المطاف ويدعي انه حقق
هذا الانتصار على اعتبار انه لم يضع
معايير معايير واضحه المعالم يمكن بناء
عليها القياس وهنا انا اذكركم في مرحله
الهدنه السابقه في مرحله الهدنه بعد تمام
الهدنه خرج بنيمين نتنياهو قبيل الهدنه
وبعد الهدنه ليؤكد مسالتين الاولى ان
العمليه العسكريه استطاعت ان تقوض او يعني
تق قلل من قدرات حماس العسكريه والمساله
الثانيه ان هذا الضعف لدى حركه حماس نتاجا
للعمليه العسكريه هو الذي قاد الى انتصار
جزئي اسرائيلي باخراج بعض المحتجزين يعني
هذه هي
المحاجي يقدمها بنيامين نتنياهو بالمناسبه
حتى جلان قدمها في بعض الاحيان وبعض اقطاب
مجلس الحرب الاسرائيل الاخرين لذلك هو
مستعد دكتور شوبكي الان ونحن ننتظر موعد
راس الساعه لانها البرنامج نسال في
النهايه سيد ايهاب جبارين عندما تدعو
رئيسه حزب العمل ل انهاء هذا التناقض بين
استمرار الحرب وا اطلاق سراح المحتجزين
وعندما ايضا لبيد يدعو الى شيء من هذا
القبيل مقابل يمين متطرف يكبل نتنياهو ان
صح التعبير كيف له ان يتصرف في
النهايه هو بدا بالتصوف بالفعل يعني ان
كنا نتحدث عن الح حروب بالوكاله هو كذلك
احد الامور التي يقوم بها الان هو حرب
استباقيه يقوم بتضليل معالم هذه الحرب الى
ايه اهداف هي خرجت عندما يبدا يتحدث ويركز
على حديث الدوله الفلسطينيه وعدم وجود
وجوب وجود الدوله الفلسطينيه بمفاهيم كذه
هذه النقطه التي عليها شبه اجماع في جميع
اطياف الشارع الاسرائيلي ما بين اليمين
المتطرف وما بين المعارضه التي باغلب هي
يمين استراتيجي حتى وان كان هنالك بعض
الاطراف التي تؤمن انه يجب ان يكون دوله
فلسطينيه لكنها بكل تاكيد يجب ان تكون وفق
الشروط التي تريدها اسرائيل بالمقام الاول
وبعيده الامد فبالتالي هو يقوم بهذه
الغربله الاستراتيجيه في في ظل كل هذه
المعالم وبالذات بان الان اسرائيل تمر
بمرحله تنفيس المركز يعني في على مدى
العقد الاخير كان هنالك اسرائيل اطيافها
السياسيه تمركزت الان هي تتم بمرحله تنفيذ
وهو يحاول استقطاب هذه الاصوات حول قضيه
الدوله الفلسطينيه عد عدم وجود الدوله
الفلسطينيه هو يجب ان يكون الروايه
الاسرائيليه النتيف الاسرائيلي هذا في
المقام الاول وبالتالي هو يحاول ان يسيطر
على كل هذا الاجماع ويؤكد بانه هذا هو
الهدف في نهايه المطاف من اخر هذه الحرب
في حال لم ينجح في تحقيق الهدفين الاولين
شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتب المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ايهاب جبرين كنت معنا من
الناصره شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من الخليل
الدكتور بلال الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الخليل بهذا مشاهدينا
الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه موعدنا بحول الله يتجدد كالعاده
تمام الثامنه والنص بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
للوقوف في محطات تحليليه عند اخر التطورات
الخاصه بهذا الملف